- Hey guys, first of all,
thank you for clicking.
You're about to watch a new video,
or another video on YouTube.
And, before you do, 212-931-5731.
If you are getting value
out of my YouTube videos,
what I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers,
it's instant, it's access, it's exclusive,
and it's just been a lot of fun.
And I've just enjoyed texting back
and forth with a lot of you.
212-931-5731.
I'm sure they're editing something, team.
I know how you do it.
Please join my texting community.
And now, enjoy this YouTube video.
Hey, guys, just 'cause AJ's here,
so you don't really have to do anything,
A.J. but at least say hello.
- Yeah.
- AJ, who runs Vayner Sports,
obviously you guys know who AJ is.
well, a lot of you don't.
Nonetheless, something
I want to do more of is
make some video content that
goes a little bit deeper
into the insights of things
that don't get shown.
So I want to make this video as a little
state of the union of Vayner Sports.
Some content of different meetings
and different things I can show.
Some updates, some highlights.
- Yep.
- Just a fun little Vayner Sports video.
You'll probably see more about this from
Sasha from Wine Library, from Empathy.
Starting a series of insight depth
looks into the other
things that are going on
by putting together a
conglomerate of four months
worth of stuff that leads to one video.
(rap music)
♪Whoa, yes, swear to God I'm with it ♪
♪I don't see nobody in my lane ♪
♪ It's quiet, go get it like me, whoa ♪
- So Snapback is one of our
partners at Vayner sports.
They make an amazing piece of apparel
that not only looks good but also helps
athletes recover and warm up their bodies.
Both hot and cold therapy.
And they wanted to partner with us
on our client list and
one of those clients,
in particular, is Leonard Williams.
Obviously Leonard's a
tremendously talented individual,
has charisma, has a great
look, and also plays in one
of the biggest markets of
the world, New York City.
- We've taken basically
three modalities that,
as an athlete, you're accustomed to.
Compression, hot therapy, cold therapy.
Simplify those and put
it into a single garment
so that you can have full mobility.
So while NormaTec, Game
Ready and those products
are great products, you
can't be ambulatory.
Yeah, you are stuck there, right.
So how can we increase
the likelihood that we can
get our athletes to incorporate
cold therapy after training?
And, like right now, in
these recovering weeks
how do we get guys sleeping in tights?
How do we make the best
compression garment in the world,
fabricated with the best materials,
that would increase the likelihood
that you'll wear this compression,
that you'll just incorporate either
our therapy pods, which can be used
for the heat or ice, or
you can use real ice,
so when you don't have access.
You weren't at the event around the ESPYS.
I know you were traveling.
But we had all the athletes using real ice
to ice after the workout.
But the way that the
product works is you've got
- [Leonard] Little pockets for them.
- [A.J.] It's even better!
- [Kevin] Yeah even better than
pockets is that you've got 360 degrees.
So you don't know where
you're gonna to be sore right?
- Yeah.
- So somebody cut blocks you and
you have a contusion on your quad.
How are you gonna wear ice on your quad?
- Right.
- Saran wrap, Ace
bandages, makes no sense.
You're not gonna do it.
- It eliminates your
mobility a little bit.
- Yeah, you have no mobility.
And then, the trainer
would love you at home
sitting there for 25 minutes icing,
but I'm gonna guess you
probably have better things
to do than sit for 25 minutes at a time.
So you can take these pods, they can
go anywhere within the garment.
It's a compression garment, right?
So when you have it on these micro grips
come through the mesh
and you can run, jump,
do whatever you want and
the ice is not gonna move.
If you don't have access to a freezer
grab a Ziploc bag, real ice in there,
chuck it in to the product
and you can remain ambulatory.
Throw some basketball shorts on over it.
- How do you heat them up though.
- You put them in the microwave.
- Oh, okay.
Or like in the training
room, we have a lot of guys,
a lot of training staff
that are using these pods
putting them in the hydro collator.
So where they typically have
the water, the heat bag.
- Oh the heat bag.
- So these will be at 160 degrees
coming out of a hydro collator.
Throw them on the muscle areas
that you want to warm
up before your training.
Take them out, train in the garment,
when your done throw in ice.
So this is a...
- How has adoption been?
How has this season been?
You got a lot of people using it?
- Yeah, so it's actually been really,
we're proud to say we
have 100% adoption rate.
So once we meet with an athlete,
introduce the product to
them, they incorporate it.
Some guys just for travel cause this is
a properly graduated compression garment.
So guys that are on the
road, especially baseball,
sitting on a plane.
[mumbles]
You've got 70% of your
blood is beneath your heart.
You're working against gravity.
You've got to get all of
that blood that's pooling
back to your heart to get oxygen delivered
and redistributed to your muscles.
That's how you recover.
But, typically, people who don't have
compression products that actually work
'cause a lot of the
stuff in the marketplace
is not designed to
actually perform for you.
But yeah, so it is a different experience,
and obviously, probably not
going to try it on today,
but I'll text you some other information
if you have a specific question.
- And Leonard you do
what everybody else does?
Just like ice packs and shit?
- Yeah man, like you said, if we do want
to do a specific area like my quad
or something like that,
we end up wrapping it
with all these bandages
and stuff and I'm limping
to my car 'cause it's
so hard to walk with it.
You know what I mean?
So that definitely makes a lot of sense.
And then we tried that
compression type of thing
for traveling one time in college before
because we're on flights for so long
we tried these compression pants.
- That USC budget.
(group laughing)
- The school gave it to you?
- Yeah the school gave it to us yeah.
So I weren't able to keep them.
We just did it when we traveled.
- Just when you traveled?
- Yeah.
- And you liked that?
- Yeah I liked it.
So it would definitely help
like being able to travel
since I'm gonna be sitting
there for so long anyways.
(rap music)
- [Announcer] Pressure's coming on Allen.
Fires into the back in the end zone!
Touchdown Panthers it's Curtis Samuel!
- [Announcer] Daniel with the fake.
Robertson touchdown!
- [Announcer] Rodgers the
other way from the end zone.
Touchdown Geronimo Allison!
- [Announcer] Fumble it was recovered
by Jalen Reeves-Maybin.
So back-to-back weeks as you
noted, big plays by Agnew.
- So Keith Smith is one of our clients.
He plays fullback for the Atlanta Falcons
and he is somebody who I
just love riffing with.
He always has ideas and,
one idea in particular,
we were really excited to bring to life
and help Keith see his vision through.
And you know what, I'm
particularly happy about
with what Keith has done
here it's just done so well
because of how much he cares,
how authentic it is to him
and how he's also gotten
other fullbacks involved.
(rap music)
♪ Yeah, I know that I'm winnin' ♪
♪ I'm winnin', I'm
winnin', I'm winnin', wow ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, uh, I know that
I'm winnin' I'm winnin' ♪
♪ I'm winnin', I'm winnin', yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm rare, I'm rare, I'm rare ♪
♪ That shit hard I'm rare ♪
- Going into my third year in the league
I was taking it very serious
so I changed the way I was training
and where I was putting my energy.
I was focusing everything,
it was on football,
perfecting my craft.
So I went back to the
basics as far as training.
I was focused on balance,
stability, core training.
Everything like that
instead of lifting heavy.
As far as like mental and
knowledge for the game,
I started meeting with my coach more,
going over plays, spending extra time
just showing how committed I really was.
I was ready for that opportunity
I had in front of me.
So going in to the first
day of camp I was excited.
One on ones, didn't have
any team peers or anything.
Ended up getting hurt and it was just
very, very disappointing and I just
didn't understand why at the time.
Come to find out it was
a blessing in disguise.
It gave me more time to really focus
on what I wanted to do outside of football
as far as starting an
athletic apparel line
and opening a gym with my boy Robby.
So the name of the brand is Rectifyd.
This is our logo.
We went to L.A. and we met
with a lot of manufacturers
and a lot of people that
could help us with marketing,
building our own website and
just doing the whole thing.
So that's what I have been working on now.
And, after this, we're also planning on
opening a gym called Rectifyd Fitness.
So this little six month period
I'm taking my time and
energy and putting it
elsewhere instead of being depressed
and moping around and
not using my time wisely.
That's something that
I would just encourage
people to do if they
have to face adversity.
And that's what Vayner
Sports is all about.
That's something that
Gary and A.J. preach a lot
is just the athletes being successful
off the field as well
and using their platform
to be marketable and just take advantage
of being in the NFL
and using your platform
to the best of your abilities.
- So ESPYS is kinda like the
Grammy's or Oscars for sports.
It's in July every year.
And it's just a great opportunity for us
to get our guys together in L.A.
and just have a really good time.
Maybe sometimes clients haven't met yet
and we always have a good time out there.
Just throw one of our own parties.
It's just a rare opportunity
before training camp
and a great blend of entrepreneurs,
Hollywood music and sports.
- When I hear the question "What's next?"
the reality is it's a
framework of being ready
to move on something tomorrow
if that email comes in
or that dinner happens and it seem right.
So I think of myself far
more as a counter puncher
or a halftime adjustments head coach
than the one that works all week or plans.
I have one business objective,
to buy the New York Jets.
When I consume information opportunities
if I feel like that can advance it,
whether it's financial
like a big investment
or starting a company or whether it's just
optically like the Topps
deal is a money loser
from what I'm getting from Topps,
but it continues to penetrate me
into the sports consciousness
which gives me leverage in the long term.
So some of it's brand,
some of it's dollars.
But what's next is the
continuation of a framework
that allows me to respond
quickly to an opportunity
that I think is viable.
(jazz music)